so hello and welcome back to this video
just wondered somehow it looks a bit
different yeah did I screw up this is
better right this you was a bit better I
don't know I'm not quite sure because
this isn't the browser and sometimes um
somehow the browser window is different
than the recording before so I have to
adjust a little bit and yeah let's see
we have a our epic game yandi chess and
I'm going to play with a white piece and
see I've got c43 on the border against
hmm no however I will probably
mispronounced this anyway so I don't
even try i Ross okay so oh very normal
moves white clay is geared towards light
square control black the main choices
here to play with them f5 or not this
ready there should be six maybe points
towards him playing a quick Queen to d7
being ready for me
Bishop age three no he goes Bishop to e7
here mm-hmm
a couple of things saying that I can do
even a simple Knight f3 is not bad I
wonder why there should be seven what
the point of this move is
I mean why exactly not might have six
immediately or something one thing that
I wonder as well is um I wonder can go
before here immediately trying to save
the movie wand if he takes this route be
one
huh well it looks interesting let's try
this move I don't see anything
particularly wrong with it
[Music]
maybe I can save would be one I would be
interesting so let's see what he does if
he takes it I think I thought would be
one and then getting this heaven bag one
that looks okay I would assume armed and
well b5 is an annoying threat I don't
know he probably does not want to play
Knight a5
and the night I mean it doesn't have
really good square sometimes you can
jump to deform but here there is no e6
square to go to and I'm not quite sure
what is move as it looks a bit annoying
night before we won d5 doesn't work I
think due to create for it's a little
bit problematic I don't see an obvious
choice swim run it oftentimes maybe
Queen d7 actually Queen d7 b5 night to
d8 this is something that makes some
sense
yeah maybe 27
it's surprising so be fire them push the
night to 85
yeah that night
that's not a good good square for this
piece so he will play some c6 probably
and I will go away for just asked this
night about its plans I won't know how
to develop that it's really not not that
obvious
Nydia three maybe on I or III I think I
go here it just quicker good canceling
next and 92 is also possible to open up
the bishops diagonal later I feel I have
to yeah well yeah I thought a form to
stay form so that Z takes a takes can be
played
hmm I don't I don't see a really good
continuation for him maybe Knight f6 and
continue to develop d65 in the center
would be whoa really
what do you want to do here like c5 that
would be nice
then I will carefully plan this some
this is the most normal continuation so
what is he up to
I wonder if Bishop d2 is any good trying
to maybe introduce the possibility of
taking on 85 after Knight move but it's
not so clear what it actually
accomplishes we should a three
we should 83 maybe 90 form might be an
interesting idea
also Bishop before sometimes I kind of
suspect that he will place c5 anyway in
this case you can argue that the bishop
is not well placed actually huh
no it's not a big deal with after c5 now
I mean this is strategically have
certainly a little bit dubious for
Blackfoot maybe not downright terrible
if you go c5 and then my bishop really
looks a bit stupid well we'll see what
is clans are
Oh
if I just take on these on c6 I would
have really really nice control over the
light squares maybe this is a way to go
but currently he's not threatening c5 in
any way some this is not particularly
urgent can I increase the pressure there
somehow I mean if the next move will
probably be careful
mmm now not quite sure how I can put
more pressure here on physics that looks
difficult to do yeah some something like
the habit it's not super convincing
maybe that tempts them into 95 after
which I will happily take my bishop is
really not that great and it would lead
to a position where I dominate on the
light squares yeah we'll see 95 I will
take I am expecting to just castle here
it's really the most obvious mujer to
Castle this one man I don't know if this
is so good I can take some I can take on
g6 and play 95 it looks annoying and it
does I don't need to think about this so
long this is just good so yeah all
captures seem promising that this must
be and must be as strong which should be
right or the best one let's say because
this is fantastic square so yeah this is
CERN my interesting I mean come on let's
do it let's do it and play it simple
this is just simple any good I just hack
it off and check on c6 your starting
position is absolutely terrible for like
but I have to be aware of however is
that Bishop c6 it runs a5 after this so
probably this is better I'm just winning
the a pond I wanted to do that
like check King moves and then clean a
four but then a five doesn't move well
actually even that was playable because
the airport is so strong but anyway I
win their seventh one and that should be
should be decisive yeah the main thing
is if you compare compare the bishops
yeah Queen c7 was a was a really really
bad move
zu v6 is the target
yeah not fun
there's also an absolutely weak square
on d5 that would be a good square for my
night in the future the night only two
currently it's not perfectly placed it
would really like to be on c3 but it's
it's fine I mean it's very fine how to
do at night be one might be one two
three a form this kind of maneuvers but
a move that I like here is this one this
is just putting the bishop on that
secure square and I'm ready in some
cases to just snap off the night if it
comes on to d7 like this here I'm going
to take this I know it looks maybe a
little bit illogical but it is a strong
maneuver because I get the knight now to
d5 and that a piece distribution which
is hugely favorable for me the knight on
d5 against that terribly bad bishop so I
am not unhappy about this trait of my
bishop it was a very strong piece but it
matters what you get not what you've
given up and what I get is a dominating
night against the bad bishop there was
some care conversion on those operation
to convert and what kind of an advantage
to to the other this is really really
important to get to evaluate those
correctly this was not the only way
forward but it is a way to yeah put this
to make some progress let's say and
change the position to ultimately get a
win yeah
so I guess II for now no F for well I
was thinking if on to undermine my
position a little bit okay so let's go
95 then I expect be 58 and then I play
with a 1 for a 8 this one okay can so
bring the king up if I like there's no
need really I cannot suggest do this and
try to trade
and the bishop will never take anything
I also have this simple maneuver to
improve it improve the position I mean I
don't don't have a an idea here to even
fight
okay take towards the center
[Music]
you
yo probably flakiness heaven or
something like that
yeah with this one I like to trade one
look so that the remaining rook can
enter here on the same drink on the
eighth-ranked one of those was
unavoidable yeah now the bishop cannot
move and to the rook is also limited it
can just shuffle between b8 and c8 so I
have an easy plan I just bring the king
up and then see how we defense the e5
pawn I guess he doesn't actually yeah he
tries to play a g5 + g5 + H form I can
actually play for checkmate here g5 king
up no no it moves the bishop yeah well
it covers ePHI for the time being
and that's no way to play for me ii
would like to do that but doesn't really
work
okay let's win the porn nb6 should be
should be lost through
okay let's giving the porn it's not
necessary cannot defend v6 Andy five
turn the rook it's not exactly having
many squares I just enter here the king
maybe and push the e-pawn all the way up
the board maybe those well making make
him resign this it looks like complete
torture anyway no almost play a 45 and
so on no matter what
[Music]
rook e8 and king c6 it's also pretty
strong okay so let's let's bring the
porn look try to go over them but where
are you putting your bishop actually you
cannot he cannot cover it and if you
move that I'm going to just attack it
I think the bishop is almost almost gone
now to h6 okay let's run with the upon
King - and keep the c6 is actually
trapping the rook that's funny
rook has no square not a single square
after King to c6
yeah he's really taking his free time in
this totally busted position okay now he
resigned
yeah Litella look at the game so would
we what do we see
oh I made one blunder what blunder did I
make actually maybe it's some kind of
thing where I had +10 and I just had +3
or something like that where was the
blunder plunder f3 blunder
because it just trusts six or something
okay yeah well I can live with that
when I when you win with every move and
you just play I don't know third best
order so um we had this English opening
and that's completely no opposition here
they usually play 27 after which White
has some some choice eform III hope you
won they're all decent moves yeah after
this I came up with this immediate
before I'm not sure I felt it was an
interesting idea hm seems to yeah it's
impacted it threw him off a little bit
if he if he takes
[Music]
just thank someone energetic and yeah if
he takes Queen B 3 is actually even
stronger than rupee 1 and they both look
good but I mean this must be must be
fine something like that whites whites
better okay so he played the move Bishop
to d7 I was not quite sure what the
point was I mean this was still kind of
normal-looking white is probably better
here with the space but nothing
particularly impressive a Bishop d7
looked a bit like it was his time and
puts that night on the edge of the board
play day for him and now b6 is deemed
inaccurate yeah
then it weakens the light squares and
particularly c6 this is this now I
wasn't sure which should be three years
even one of the engines top three
choices maybe 92 especially I don't know
I wasn't sure later if this is really
such a good square for the piece Knight
f6 90 to 97 yeah it looks kind of normal
interestingly enough Queen c7 it's not a
mistake according to the computer
because I because Queen d8 is actually
still still playable okay I didn't quite
didn't quite proceed as well it's not
very difficult to see but I didn't quite
have it on the right now
yeah I mean your white must have a
little something but it's it's nothing
spectacular the line that the engine
gives is interesting because here it
wants to go a 598 create form try to use
that app in this this okay hmm yes it
looks very promising but after the
capture it's just just gone basically a
father's too much yeah like this and
what I want to mentioned is that this is
something that was an issue but I even
during the recording I realized that I
can just take off course because this is
not working for him but there's nothing
wrong word tween a father the porn just
drops and this is just a winning
position this should be three yeah maybe
a bit that is a technical bin and Eddie
nearly wanted yeah taking what's making
things easier yeah I was expecting to
play for some some sort of mucho I don't
know stir up some trouble I don't know
what's wrong exactly but just to do
something active I mean I would have
played ninety five just ignore
everything and play a very strong night
against very weak Bishop scenario where
I'm a pawn up the deep on is not going
to clean anytime soon but it's still
important to keep the pawn chain a
formal and yeah I'm slowly even getting
a big advantage
yeah kini for we have across that
blunder like the engine says how are
okay who b6y Paulie I saw that that I
can take the average I mean you can he
cannot move I mean Geoffrey is
completely enough just very simple very
simple win here with the pawns marching
marching home yeah hey guys thanks for
watching